i'm sure you've heard this a million
times you need to eat your fruits and
vegetables right they kind of lump in
the fruits with the vegetables which is
interesting but i want to differentiate
these two and kind of separate them out
and talk about some interesting things
about fruit first of all when we talk
about the vegetables that the majority
of the population eats especially in the
u.s
it's not salads actually it's
corn peas and potatoes so there's
definitely some problems with these
vegetables which i don't want to get
into in this video
i want to mainly focus in on fruit the
last time i did a video on fruit um
boy i stirred up a hornet's nest a lot
of people were not happy because they
love their fruit so i'm just going to
give you the data you can take it or
leave it but i want you to be aware of a
few things number one fruits have at
least five times the amount of sugar
than veggies okay the second thing
that's kind of surprising for people
when they look at this is 85 percent of
that fruit is sugar it makes up the
great majority of the fruit itself and
yes there is vitamin c in fruit no
doubts okay there's vitamin c and a good
amount of it and there's also
phytonutrients which is great okay
and there's fiber okay which is
wonderful
but
very low protein okay you could not even
get close to getting your protein
requirements if you
have done fruit okay so there's very
little protein
very little fat you might think that's a
good thing but
we need fat very low iron
and very low b vitamins there's no b12
for sure low calcium low zinc
low omega-3 fatty acids if any at all
and low vitamin d if any at all so if in
your mind you are eating fruit for
health reasons because you want to get
your nutrients
you might want to look at getting it
from something else now out of all the
fruits there's some fruits that have low
amounts of sugar and those would be fine
if you have them in small amounts like
let's say half a cup or a cup a day like
berries for example like 3.5 ounces of
raspberry will only give you 5 grams so
that's pretty low and then we have
blackberries 5 grams
blueberries 12 grams a little bit more
but you know doable
strawberries 6 grams
so if you can eat berries if you just
focus on raspberries and blackberries
and maybe strawberries you're going to
be better off now what about kiwi people
always ask me about kiwi well if we take
three and a half ounces of a kiwi it's
14 grams i mean not off the charts if
you have small amounts of it it's going
to be fine but one thing about kiwi
that's very unique is that
it's off the charts as far as amounts of
vitamin c so it does have a lot of
vitamin c it does have a good amount of
nutrients compared to other fruits but i
will say it's very high in oxalates so
if you're sensitive
to oxalates or you are prone to kidney
stones
don't do the kiwi i'm sorry i guess some
mr bad news today
all right let's also talk about the
sugar in fruit
it has fructose it has glucose as well
but it has fructose fructose sugar is
very unique in that
only the liver can metabolize it all the
cells in your body cannot metabolize
fructose they can metabolize glucose but
not fructose and so because fructose is
low in the glycemic index
you might say wow it's totally fine but
it's not because it's going to overload
the liver
and what's unique about fructose is that
there's going to be less suppression of
ghrelin which means you're going to be
less satisfied so you're going to have a
tendency to eat more fruit but if you're
doing
like high fructose corn syrup like you
can just down a lot of that and you just
won't get satisfied also when you
consume excess fructose it can spike
cortisol and then that can increase
insulin indirectly you're also going to
create a situation where you're going to
be less sensitive to insulin which leads
to insulin resistance
okay
and that leads to a fatty liver
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease so
people that consume a lot of fructose
whether it's from high fructose corn
syrup or they're consuming a lot of
fruit can end up with a fatty liver and
insulin resistance indirectly and that
can create a cascade of issues which i'm
sure you've seen in a lot of my videos
my recommendation would be to
eat your vegetables okay eat your
vegetables skip the fruit maybe have a
little bit of berry
maybe an occasional kiwi if you want but
other than that vegetables have a lot
less sugar they have the fiber they have
nutrients that's what you should be
focusing on now since we mentioned sugar
in the glycemic index i want to give you
some more information
about something called the glycemic load
okay which is very important and i put
that video up right here check it out